today's question ayo comes from calista
in nebraska she
says i'm a dental hygienist but i'm
considering getting a bachelor's degree
in something that would be more
fulfilling
and give me more opportunities i'd love
to be a teacher
but the pay is not the best i've also
considered nursing school
because of the potential income but i
wonder
if i would end up feeling unfulfilled
again
do i choose my career based on finances
or adjust my finances for the career the
answer is and
always will be if you ask me be
you must always choose what you were
created to do
and you adjust your lifestyle to that i
mentioned this earlier
teachers who across the nation
the median income is 60 000 they are the
third largest group of everyday
millionaires which means they live
on less than they make they are very
fulfilled in other words
they've got plenty of income because
they're working for impact and i say
this on the ken coleman show
every day when i start the show you were
created to contribute
you were created to work you don't work
to live you live to work and that
doesn't mean becoming a workaholic and
putting all your value in your paycheck
what it means is
you were created to contribute that's
why everybody that i talked to on the
show ao who calls in and they're very
confused can i don't know what i want to
do with my life i just want to help
people everybody says that because we
all long to make a difference so
the answer is figure out what you're
supposed to do you can call my show
we'll do a deep dive with you
uh once you figure it out you adjust
your lifestyle to that you know what ken
i want to add something to that
all right not really necessary to the
question but to the point you just made
and i really want america to hear this
out well how is it that
teachers who are making on average
median income
uh making 60 thousand dollars a year
right
but then they are retiring millionaires
yeah i i i i want to teach right here
from the money principal do it you say
live below your means that's how they're
doing it they're living below their
means they're paying off their debt
and then also in that same study that we
did we found out that also paying off
their mortgage yes
watch this uh when they retire if they
have
one million dollars in their retirement
funds
and then they just let's say they just
draw the interest only don't pull from
the 1 million
let's just say the interest is 10 at
that time it's a hundred thousand
dollars
so i know america probably probably
saying where are you gonna get ten
percent from
that added up well i can talk to that
too but let's just go down to the low
end
let's say it's eight percent that's
eighty thousand dollars
so when she retires she's debt-free has
a million dollars in her account and she
gets a 20 000
pay raise yeah that's right to go retire
why because over a period of time she
didn't chase
money she chased happiness and while she
was chasing her happiness
her fulfillment like you taught she's
living the money principles that
that we teach live below your means you
know have the nice things pay off your
debt stay away from debt and so when she
retires not only she has seven figures
that she could pass down
to her kids and to her kids kids but she
gets a twenty thousand dollar
when she stops working and she can now
go enjoy life
i just had to add that in there it's
great for all y'all people saying oh you
gotta make a million dollars a year no
you don't know
and not only did he make the financial
case let me make the soul case
not only has she had a raise in
retirement
she's going to get to the end of her
journey look back and reminisce
not regret so good and that's what this
journey is all about